since south i steam room every activity
and officer elections you ever give
notice of the remote record of threes
calendar that the said election missus
follows Robin bhar Liberal Democrats
3335 Kevin balance training associates
coalition 238 necklace John Banks Labour
Party to 3 17 18 Stephanie Davis Green
Party on some 65 multiple-dose Wiggly UK
dependents arting 4909 david john bowers
consider quality couple of 25
well thank you very much a professor
compared to you first of all awful
administering and it count all of your
people here it's going to say tonight
this morning the Birchwood the virtua
dawn to all of the all of the people
outside who administer the ballot boxes
as well as a thank you for doing that so
efficiently thank you also to the
candidates for the still-standing having
to two of two of left everybody that
stands the lecture puts themselves to
scrutiny and tries to make a
contribution to our public life
everybody should be respected after
doing that I also want to thank all my
staff some of whom are here this has
been a huge effort in
people involved in this in particular
and my agent
I want to thank donors of wallington
South five years ago they did with
enormous privilege of elected me as
their members of parliament time over
the last five years to discharge that
privilege effectively and so in the next
five years as well and willing to this a
special place and we need to continue to
grow very much forward to doing that
thank you all very much
you